from the director of the pilot episode
of the Cape comes the machinist mechanic
Nicky machinist different movie
altogether like all together the
mechanic that's what I meant
now the mechanics the story of Jason
Statham who's a hit man from the trailer
we thought all right transporter 9
how many unofficial transporter sequels
can we possibly handle turns out it's
kind of like that kind of not it starts
out hitman Jason Statham takes out a guy
it looks all cool he's doing the Metal
Gear Solid 2 like jumping off a bridge
and and then against all human
logic and Hitman code he takes on a
Protege like this hitman Padawan played
by Ben Foster but why would he do that
makes no sense now it would be cool
seeing a hitman train a hitman protege
if that was what the movie was about or
if it made any sense whatsoever but the
movies like for movies and one it's like
the movie has no idea what it wants to
be it's kind of like Eddie Izzard you
know transvestite not transvestite it
just doesn't know like Ben Foster he
knows from the get-go he's a little over
the top so he's like oh I'll train you
to be a hitman you know kind of give you
a path you know I saw it in a movie once
I don't know it worked out then and
Statham chokes a guy out right in front
of Ben Foster because the first guy Ben
Foster has ever seen died you'd think
he'd just like have to deal with that
like it'd be a monumental thing Statham
was all like I want you to say it
face-to-face and Ben Foster's nothing
he's like Oh guys dead look at that
that's interesting I don't know you
choked him out I I feel nothing which is
weird I mean unless you're Dexter Morgan
that is weird you'd think he'd have to
deal with that but now you know life
goes on it's all good it's like the
Frankenstein of hitman movies it's like
someone saw a bunch of hitman movies and
took parts from those hitman movies and
sewed it all into one movie it's like a
bionic hitman movie Franken hit man so
I'm gonna call it and most of the fights
in this movie do that that shaky-cam
thing you know the Ridley Scott where
you can't see what's going on then also
then someone's like you know dead you
don't see how it happened kind of
annoying but there is one fight that had
a couple of really sweet hits I was like
that's bad I alright that's cool
other than that the physics didn't make
sense the premise didn't make sense it
was like some exec and some studio said
all right Jason Statham and Ben Foster
action guy good actor guy we got to get
those two together
I don't know movie with guns and
I'm just making it happen it's like The
Phantom Menace mindset you know if
everyone
saw the transporter goes to this movie
it'll make its money back if everyone
sees it once make some quick cash no
support that that is so I
would say and I have a feeling I'm gonna
be way too nice to this movie but this
is just how I see it is it would be an
okay time if you are shit-faced hammered
drunk yeah party movies made no sense to
me you're like not at all if you get
dragged to this movie make sure you're
just nice and toasty so you can just
make fun of the movie the whole time
maybe then you'll have some fun maybe
then I just described a alright
it's so there it is transporter
9 directed by the director of the pilot
episode of the Cape no but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more